>>Female Presenter: So today we have a special
guest.
He is a successful entrepreneur, a family
man, and a graduate of the Stanford School
of Business.
He has counseled companies such as Dell, Apple,
and Microsoft and is currently on the board
of directors for Kayak.com and also the awesome
Habitat for Humanity.
In his current position he's raised over 400
million in private funding.
But at the end of the day still has time for
himself, friends, and family and to make a
fresh margarita when he gets home.
Please welcome Brian Sharples of HomeAway.
[applause]
[cheers]
>>Brian: Hi.
Thanks for having me.
Really cool space.
I can't wait to tour it.
Very jealous.
But it's great to be here.
Google is actually a major partner of ours.
Susan Wojcicki is on our board of directors,
now.
And Google Ventures is an investor in our
company.
And so I know a fair amount about Google.
We've worked with them a lot.
You guys work for an amazing company.
It's obviously the most entrepreneurial big
company in the world and certainly the most
successful tech company of all time.
Facebook might argue that.
But I still give it to Google.
For sure.
And so I'm not really sure what I can tell
you that Google doesn't teach you.
'Cause you guys are in such a great environment.
But I'll try.
I really appreciate being here.
I've been an entrepreneur most of my life.
And so I'm gonna talk very quickly about some
lessons learned along the way.
I'm told that you guys have a long weekend
and so many of you wanna scoot out of here
as quick as you can.
So I'll be relatively brief.
And you know, for those of you who wanna hang
around and ask questions, I'll certainly stay
as long as need be.
But we're gonna start by rolling a little
piece of old video.
[video theme music plays]
>>Male announcer: First in the Bay Area.
This is The 10' O'clock News on Channel 2.
The number one prime time newscast in the
country
>>Elaine Corral: If you're thinking about
buying a car, but can't afford a new one,
this might be your lucky weekend.
Final preparations are underway at San Francisco
Candlestick Park tonight for the grand opening
of what's called the International Used Auto
Expo.
>>Male Reporter #1: It's playing host to what's
being billed as the world's largest used car
sale.
>>Male Reporter #2: it's being transformed
into the world's largest used car showroom.
>>Male Salesman: We got deals.
We got everything.
We got foreign cars.
We got domestic cars.
We got it all.
Great prices.
I'm Crazy Brian and I'm doin' this for a living.
[upbeat music]
[music changes to rock music]
[music slows way down]
[dog barks]
[dramatic music]
>>Male on phone: I think it's happening.
>>Male Reporter #3: Meteorologists are at
a loss to explain what is causing this weather.
>>Male Reporter #4: A twister in Los Angeles.
[sound of wind and people panicking]
>>Male Pilot: Massive
[sound of airplane and wind]
>>Male Salesman: People selling cars.
People are buying cars.
People seem happy.
It's a sunny day.
The wind has stayed under 30 mile per hour
today.
It's a lovely wind, I mean it actually feels
good.
>>Reporter: [inaudible]
>>Male Salesman: Things are much better.
No tents fell down.
Nobody's been killed.
We haven't had a major fire.
>>Female Reporter: [inaudible]
>>Male Salesman: The earth has not shaken
once.
So there are lots of things happening.
>>Reporter: [inaudible]
[rock music]
>>Brian: Year ago.
That's when most of you were, I don't know,
in kindergarten or something.
That's how I am.
But.
That was the first, I had done some other
business.
Stupid business stuff before.
But that was the first time I'd ever taken,
ventured, a million dollars.
That I lost in a matter of three hours.
It was a big idea.
Like HomeAway.
But the used car market was all screwed up.
I was buyin' a car at the time.
And had to drive all over San Francisco.
I was like "God, it's such a pain in the ass.
These people.
Everybody's sellin', everybody's buyin'.
Just get 'em together all at one place.
And we'll do it all over the country.
Multiple times a year.
So people don't have to go through this."
Right?
And built this huge thing.
And brought in, built the world's biggest
car store on site.
Mile long test track.
All this kinda stuff.
So we had like 20 bands playing for this thing.
And it actually, all on Day 1 after about
three hours of opening, a freak storm came
in with about 75 mile an hour winds and just
completely leveled the place.
We had a--, I remember we had this big finance
operation we built.
'Cause we were actually making a lot of our
money financing cars in this particular deal.
And we had this giant tent that was about
50 computers at the time it was just like.
Big fat IBM PCs and all that.
Just all that completely destroyed in San
Francisco Bay.
And there I was with my first deal.
I knew I had lost everything at the end of
that.
But the next day we actually put a team of
about 500 people, including I think we grabbed
like the University of San Francisco football
team and worked all night trying to put it
back together.
But by the second day it was pretty clear
we weren't going to recoup the money.
So that was my sorta first deal.
And here I am now, 20 something years later.
And I'm fortunate enough to have a really
nice success under my belt with HomeAway.
Which isn't really the success of Google but
it's been a really great ride.
And the thing I wanna talk about I guess the
most is, how that experience really led to
HomeAway being successful today.
I was being interviewed yesterday at my home
by Entrepreneur Magazine.
And they asked me this question.
Which was, you know "If you had to do it all
again, based on what you know now, what would
you do differently?"
And my response to them was "I wouldn't do
anything differently.
I love everything that happened."
'Cause the reality is that failing is, in
my opinion, and the thing I've learned, is
probably the biggest key to success.
I love people who have tried big things and
failed.
And, you guys, live in a company environment
where you're allowed to take pretty big risks.
And I know Google is OK with failure.
And that's a really, really important thing.
And so as I've, if you wanna click the slide.
I think the first, when you're a young entrepreneur.
And nobody's probably looking at Google well,
how many people really don't wanna work here
but wanna start your own company some day.
Yeah.
See.
Everybody does.
Right?
So you probably already have an idea.
And there are lots of great ideas out there.
I get ideas all the time.
But the thing that I think I learned very
early on from that venture is that the, ideas
are important.
And you need to have good ideas.
But execution is way more important.
Clicking to the next slide.
Than ideas.
That execution is everything in business.
And most of what I've learned through the
failures I've had are to focus very very heavily
on execution.
And if you click to the next slide.
Execution, I think, has a lot to do with not
just kind of optimism.
And being all entrepreneurs wanna think that
they're business is gonna be a huge success.
You've got an idea.
It's gonna be great.
They're always forward thinking, forward leaning.
And I'm like that too.
I'm like the eternal optimist.
But at that age, all I could think about was
what would go right.
And everybody who comes to you with a business
plan, that's all they ever talk about.
Is what's gonna go right.
And the projections are always super rosy.
But over the years when you sort of mature
at doing this stuff and fail a few times,
you learn that probably the most important
thing to focus on is not what's gonna go right.
But what could go wrong.
And you know, it's like being a little kid.
You touch the fire on the stove and you're
never gonna do it again.
When negative things happen, it causes this
reaction in you where you're just gonna work
so hard in your life to make sure it never
happens again.
Which is why I love, again, when I hire people
I always ask them.
"Tell me about something you failed at.
And what did you learn from that?" and people
who haven't had those failures don't have
those muscles that they flex to be cautious
about things.
So HomeAway was a company that we knew there
was a big opportunity.
Here's this vacation rental market.
Nobody touched it.
It's a worldwide market.
It's out there for the picking.
The companies that were in that business were
all relatively small and underfunded.
But at the same time even though we couldn't
find a big competitor, when we started building
the company, we said "Look.
OK.
We know we can do this.
We know we can do a better job.
But let's really think through all the things
that can go wrong here."
And one of the biggest things that entrepreneurs
don't think through is, they'll look out in
the marketplace and say "Ah.
I've got this great idea.
And nobody else has this product.
See?
It's fantastic.
Nobody else has this.
Nobody's doing this."
Well, that's an irrelevant question.
The question is, if you're successful doing
it, who's gonna now come in and do it.
Right?
I mean, and most people don't think that way
but you have to role play and scenario plan
for those kinds of things.
And so in the case of HomeAway for example,
we knew, and of course the world is really
changed now.
You come up with a hot idea and there are
people cloning it left and right as fast as
possible.
And so one of the things you have to do in
today's environment, is if you've got a great
idea, part of being paranoid is, a.
staying somewhat quiet.
A lot of people like to talk about what they're
doing.
A little too early.
With HomeAway, even though we were really
successful from the first days, we didn't
really say much about the business for the
first three or four years.
And our investors would say "Why aren't you
out there in the press doing this and that?"
And we're like, "Well, because we're not in
Germany yet.
We're not in France yet.
We.
Shhh.
This is a really good business.
We don't wanna tell anybody about it."
And that was sort of part of our paranoia.
Part of our paranoia was we knew that we were
in a marketplace business.
Much like Google is.
If you're searching for stuff, you're gonna
go the place where the most relevant results
are.
And where there's relevant results you're
gonna be served by having the most people
using that service and making them better.
And so HomeAway is the same thing.
We knew that controlling supply, controlling
demand, being the biggest in our business
was gonna be our key core competitive advantage.
So we had to get as big as we could as fast
as we could.
You know, conventional wisdom when you're
an entrepreneur starting out is "I wanna retain
as much of the company as I can for myself.
I don't wanna bring in too many investors.
Or sell stock."
Well this was one where I said, you know what
it's either gonna work or it's not.
And if it's gonna work.
And we have to assume that Expedia is gonna
come into the business.
There was a time when we thought Google was
gonna come into the business.
I don't believe that anymore for a number
of reasons.
You know, Trip Advisor was gonna come to the
business.
So let's just assume that's gonna happen.
And run really fast.
And run really fast for us meant, we don't
even have time to build it.
We'll build it and we'll build a platform
called HomeAway.
But there's already a leader in Germany, let's
go buy 'em.
. There's already a leader in France, let's
. So we ran around the world.
The day we opened the company, we bought five
companies in the first day.
But that takes a ton of money, which takes
away from equity for me and everybody else
who was starting the company.
But that was irrelevant to us because again,
it was about managing risk.
I will give up equity, to manage that risk.
Somebody said we raised 400 million.
I mean, when we did our, I guess it was our
third venture round in 2008, 250 million.
I mean it was the biggest venture round for
a tech company in nine years.
And we gave up, well, how could we do it?
But we did it because again, we were sort
of paranoid about making sure we were the
biggest.
You know, we were gonna get there first.
I think the other thing that we did in a very
disciplined way as a team was also that very
paranoid, just managing our money and managing
our costs.
'Cause that's the other thing that gets a
lot of people in trouble.
I look at this auto expo business that I was
putting together.
There was a ton of risks in that.
That I didn't really fully appreciate and
understand.
One of them was obviously the weather.
I should have gone out and bought insurance
for the weather.
Now I had done a little bit of research, and
the wind had actually never gotten over 70
miles an hour.
On that day in San Francisco.
But sure enough it did.
I probably could have done some things to
protect myself.
So if you go to the next slide.
I think probably the biggest word that comes
to mind in terms of my learnings about how
to manage risk is curiosity.
Is that you, again, it's such a, people have
such a tendency to focus on all the things
that go right.
But you have to be really curious about the
things that can go wrong.
And I love when entrepreneurs come to me with
business plans and they're curious, even,
about all the things that can go wrong.
I hate seeing somebody who's just all about
the positive.
All about the positive.
You have to be intellectually honest that
you don't know everything.
So curiosity means doing your research.
In fact, I remember with HomeAway in the beginning.
Carl and I founded the business, we had a
very different about how HomeAway would work.
And I don't know how much you guys know our
business.
It's actually a pretty simple business.
It's like a classified marketplace.
The biggest site in the world is a company
called VRBO.
VRBO's a very basic looking site.
In fact, it's funny, when I first started
getting into business, I remember starting
to do my research.
And there was VRBO and I looked at that site
and I said "No. that can't be working.
That thing's awful."
And I spent four months going down another
path.
A path of "Ah, we're gonna build this big
integrated online booking system for the vacation
rental industry."
And then ultimately, we got really curious.
And we came back to VRBO and said "Wait a
second.
Let's count.
There's this many listings.
They're charging this much money.
Right?
So that's a pretty good business."
So let's call up their customers and call
up their owners.
And our owners loved them.
When we called the travelers, the travelers
loved them.
I hated the site.
I've gotta be honest.
I couldn't use it.
But it didn't matter.
We did enough research.
We were curious enough to turn over all the
different rocks.
And ultimately we picked a model that everyone
even who was backing us said "Really, that's
kind of a simple, just classified marketplace?"
Well that was the model that was right in
the industry.
It didn't necessarily feel right to us.
But that's what the research told us.
And that's what our curiosity told us.
So, being curious is super important.
And then I think, the last big thing is, it's
hard to be curious if you aren't humble.
Which is the next word I'll put up there too.
Which is you can't, I think, you know, people
and teams are so important to businesses.
Probably one of my biggest learnings, I think
the other, if you go back to Auto Expo.
I was doing it all myself.
I grabbed a bunch of friends and people I
know to help me put the thing together.
The operations crew that put the event together
was the, were the guys who produced Grateful
Dead concerts.
'Cause I was a deadhead at the time.
And knew some of these guys.
You know I was "Come on, just do this thing."
And you know, as you get older and more seasoned
what you start to realize is, you can't do
everything.
You don't have every skill.
I've got, on a spectrum of 10 things that
you need to do well to run a good business,
I maybe have one or two of those 10 things.
And so you learn to be humble about that.
Appreciate the things you're good at.
Appreciate the things you're not good at.
If you're gonna start a business.
Starting business is about a team.
And a team really isn't necessarily about
friendship.
A team should be about complimentary skills.
And about bringing on people who can help
mitigate the risk that you're not good at.
I hate legal stuff.
Because it's minutia for me.
I can't deal with that sorta stuff.
I hate the details of accounting.
And I'm not very good at offsets.
I'm not a programmer.
I'm not a developer.
I can't do those things.
And so again, with HomeAway, after all those
kinda years of doing things.
Some worked.
A little bit.
Some, this is actually my second public company.
Some failed.
You really start to think hard about building
that team.
And I think the other right thing we did with
HomeAway is we brought in extraordinary people.
It's really the thing I admire the most about,
I was at Google Zeitgeist earlier this year.
And I got to meet Sergey and his focus on
people and how you guys hire, and just how
important that is, is dead on.
Congratulations that you all made the filter.
I don't think I would.
Oh, ha-ha-ha, Justin did.
He used to work for us.
But somehow he got.
[laughter]
Somehow he's, he, slipped the rope.
But the whole, [laughs] but the whole people
aspect seriously is very important and I think
if you're ever going to go out and raise money
and try to start a business, I guarantee you
that you will do better if you're humble than
if you're cocky.
Even when we were doing that 250 million dollar
round, and we closed it actually on the lowest
day in the market.
In the last nine years.
It was right in the financial crisis and it
was when everything literally burst.
And we ended up closing that deal at a very
high price.
The price that we had negotiated six months
prior.
I held my ground on it.
And I remember after that decision was made
and it got funded.
And there was one very big, TCV put in 175
million of that money.
And we all went to a bar afterwards to have
a beer.
And I, now that the thing was closed, I said,
I was talking to the partners and I said "Man,
why didn't you guys just really put the screws
down?
And tell us that we gotta do it at half the
price or whatever?"
He said "You know."
He said "Brian, I gotta tell you, you're the
first guy who's come into this office in 10
years who we've asked, how good is your product
on a scale of one to 10?"
And you said "I think it's a three."
And he said "We've just never heard that before.
We loved it."
People love to hear that stuff.
That you're humble about it.
You can get better.
So word of advice.
I'd be certainly more inclined to invest if
you do that.
And then I really already talked about this.
The people and the partners.
And the importance of all that.
And just again, I think HomeAway's been a
dream deal for me because I get to work with
board members I chose.
And the management team I chose.
And lots of people I chose.
You know Tiff right here is now a very senior
person in our market organization.
Used to be the nanny for my kids.
10 years ago.
[laughter]
I mean, it's a real, you know, you get, surround
yourself with really terrific people and terrific
things are gonna happen.
So that's really just sort of the formal talk
and I'd be happy to, it wasn't that formal,
to take any questions you guys might have.
Right.
>>Female Presenter: [inaudible] We'll take
some from the Dory.
So I have one from Jeremy.
How did you and other founders accelerate
the growth and profitability of HomeAway?
Was it by transforming the "how" of what you
did, and not just "what"?
>>Brian: You know, our company is going through
phases.
And it's still very much an unwritten book.
And when people try to pat us on the back
for the success of the company, I don't really
like to claim victory yet.
'Cause I think we're in pretty early stages
with the business.
Early on, we, I think what we did is we recognized
that there was a good market out there.
And we consolidated it.
And we did it a lot by acquisition.
And we built a technology platform that would
allow us to integrate those acquisitions together.
But that was so much work.
To just do that.
Just to set up an international business that
quickly and run around the world doing it.
That we frankly haven't had historically a
lot of time to focus on the how to make it
better.
That's where we are now.
So we've gotten ourselves in a market position
where we're clearly the leader in the business.
And I'm still of the same opinion when people
say what's the quality of your product or
your experience?
On a scale of one to 10.
Well, it was probably three a couple years
ago when we were raising that money.
I think we're up to a five or a six.
But we're, you know, but you should be for
a business like us, market leader, you should
be a nine.
Somewhere in that range.
So that's really something we're just going
to work on now.
How to make the experience as good as it can
be.
We've set a pretty high bar for that.
Which is that it should be as easy to find,
compare, and book a vacation rental as it
is to get a hotel room.
And you know how it is to get a hotel room,
right?
You just dial up Expedia, every hotel in the
world is on there.
This one's available, this one's open.
Boom.
Put it on my credit card and I'm done.
You cannot do that in our business today.
And that is the direction we're moving in,
and we're pretty excited about it.
But it's gonna take us probably three to five
years to get there.
From now.
>>Female Presenter: I have another question.
A little, it's, I've seen 89 Dead shows.
How many have you seen?
[laughter]
Where was your first show?
>>Brian: Wow.
>>Female Presenter: And it also says, my first
show was November 4th, 1985 in the Centrum
in Worcester, Massachusetts.
>>Brian: That's pretty cool.
I've probably seen, not that many.
I don't know, I've probably seen like 17,
18.
Most of them in California.
Most in places like the Greek Theater.
There actually used to be a really nice outdoor
amphitheater at Stanford which I don't think
they use anymore.
I've seen them in Red Rocks.
I've seen them in Maine.
All over the place.
I grew up in New England.
Went to Stanford.
So really in those two spots.
But, 89, that's impressive.
>>Female Presenter: [inaudible]
>>Brian: Ask them back, how old are they and
[laughter]
And can they
>>Female Presenter: Is Brad in here?
Brad?
>>Brian: And can they still function intelligently
and walk?
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: Brad?
Brad?
I have another one.
Will you share with us your fresh margarita
recipe?
>>Brian: Yes, I would be happy to.
I have the same thing every single day when
I get home.
It's actually the joy of my day.
So.
If you get a pen for this get it out.
So you have to first you need Don Julio Silver.
So well, highball glass.
Fill it with ice.
Then Don Julio Silver, one shot.
Cointreau, one shot.
No substitute.
None of this like Patron Orange or Grand Marnier
or anything.
It has to be Cointreau.
One shot exactly.
They you need three key limes.
You know the difference between key limes
and a regular lime?
Key limes are the little guys.
And you have the big ones.
So you need three key limes.
Cut 'em in half.
Squeeze 'em in, totally.
And take a fourth one, cut that in half and
just drop those little two halves in.
And then an orange, cut it in half, squeeze
half an orange in.
Shake it all up.
I'm tellin' ya, you'll have one every day.
[laughter]
>>female Presenter: Anybody have any questions
in the audience?
You wanna ask?
>>Brian: Yes.
>>Female Presenter: [inaudible] over here.
>>male #1: You read a lot about business ventures
now and a lot of investors like to see customers
before they invest.
It sounds like you guys did a lot of your
funding before you actually started the business.
Or before day one.
How did you go about that and what ideas do
you have in that realm?
>>Brian: Yeah.
I mean, we, you know, we were sort of fortunate
in that just as individuals starting the business
we weren't super financially constrained.
'Cause we'd done some stuff before.
And I had just sold a public company.
And was taking some time off.
And then Carl Shepherd who co-founded with
me used to be the CEO of Hoovers and then
they got sold to DNB and I don't think he
was even planning to go to work again.
But when we decided to do the business.
Actually Austin Ventures committed 50 million
to HomeAway.
No business plan, just one sentence.
Which is "We're going to build the world's
largest market for vacation rentals."
And they said "How?"
And we said "We don't know, but we're gonna
go find out."
But they committed the money beforehand.
And so we spent, I would say, four to five
months.
Our initial mission was, "Let's kind of search
the web.
Search our contacts.
Find anybody we can who knows anything about
the business.
Owners.
Property managers.
People who tried to get in the business before
and failed."
So one of the stories that kept coming up
when we were researching this, is that Expedia,
Expedia had already tried this.
They had already tried this and they'd completely
failed.
And it turned out that there was a company
back in 1999 called Vacation Spot.
It was started by a guy named Steve Murch.
And Vacation Spot was VRBO.
It was HomeAway.
And this was a venture backed business.
And these guys got up to, very quickly, about
a million dollars in revenue.
And Expedia came in.
The guy who was running Expedia at the time
was a guy named Rich Barton who went on to
found Zillow and some other things.
And Rich bought the company for 75 million
dollars.
Which back then was a huge deal.
Was 75 times revenue.
It was like one of these spectacular bubble
kinda deals.
Anyway, a year later, company's completely
out of business.
Gone.
And so everybody kept telling this story.
So I didn't know Barton.
So through venture capitalists, whatever.
I said "We gotta go see Barton.
I gotta figure out what the hell happened."
And so Barton agreed to meet with us.
He's in Seattle.
I flew out to Seattle.
Sat down with them.
He was kind enough to actually bring in Murch
and the other guys who had that company.
And we said "Alright.
So you guys already tried what we're about
to try.
What the heck happened to the business?"
And this was how, when I was talking earlier,
they said "Well, you know, Vacation Spot,
it was a great company.
It was a subscription business.
It was a very simple classified market place."
And Rich says "You know, we bought it.
And we're Expedia.
We charge a percentage of revenue.
So we basically said to all customers.
'Forget the subscription.
That's now free.
You're just gonna pay us 15 percent of bookings.'
Thing went out of business.
Everybody left."
But that was exactly what Carl and I were
gonna do at the time.
And so it was again, just by networking around.
We're just gonna go talk to everybody we possibly
can.
And then during that process of talking to
everybody we ended up meeting the Europeans
who had the strongest business models.
People in Brazil who have the strongest business
models.
And they all had the same thing in common.
They're all the same.
There are two things in common.
They kept them all really simple.
Classified, subscription based.
And they really understood the power of Google.
Those were the two things.
They really understood the power of Google.
So they were all so focused on SEO.
And so good at SEO.
We now, over time, have had to really diversify
our sources of traffic.
But that was the winning formula back then.
And so again I would just say, if you're starting
a company, you can't, people will see you.
Just call people.
Tell 'em you're doing research.
Whatever it is.
And if you can find, like we did, a company
that actually tried it and failed, that's
like the Holy Grail.
'Cause then you know, 'cause either you're
gonna figure out it's not doable 'cause they
really tried everything.
Or you're gonna figure out like we did, see
they just messed with the formula, and they
shouldn't have messed with the formula.
>>male #2: I just had a quick question.
It seems like most of your background is in
California.
And I was wondering how you got to Austin?
>>Brian: I got to Austin because after business
school I had a ton of debt.
And I went to work for Bain and Company, which
is a consulting company.
And I was in their San Francisco office.
And my, I had two clients in the short time
I was there.
One was Baxter Travenol in Chicago.
And the other was Dell Computer, before they
were even public.
Dell was the smallest company that Bain had
ever taken on.
We actually did an equity for work deal with
them.
And I was the head of that team.
So I would, every Sunday night, I would fly
down to Austin, Texas and I would go to the
arboretum and sit at the Friday's at a particular
spot in the bar.
The guy wouldn't even have to say anything.
He'd give me a beer and a thing of fried clams.
So gross.
They don't even have that anymore.
[laughter] But I'd sit.
And then I would stay Monday, Tuesday.
And then fly up to Chicago.
Then back to Travenol.
Couple days go back to San Francisco.
And in the process I got to know a lot of
people from Dell.
I'd go out on the lake, go water skiing.
This kinda thing.
And ultimately I just got sorta hooked on
Austin.
And came down a few years later.
So I've been here now more than I've been
anywhere.
Over 20 years.
>>male #3: I have an answer to one of your
questions.
And then a quick question.
So the answer to your question is, Brad Askins
is the Deadhead.
>>Brian: Yeah.
>>male #3: who asked the original question.
He's on our SketchUp team.
And he wanted to mention that he was on two
tours.
And to your question of how he's feeling.
He said he's still seeing trails.
[laughter]
>>Brian: Good.
Excellent.
>>male #3: My question is, you mention that
there's probably 10 skills that it takes to
make a successful business and you hold one
or two of those.
>>Brian: Yeah.
>>male #3: What would you say those skills
are for you?
>>Brian: Oh, for me it's, actually I think
there was a word behind this so I didn't click
one more I'm sorry.
I put it together like five minutes before
I came here.
So the next word is "passion."
One of 'em is, despite the fact that I counsel
people to be humble, you do have to be super
passionate about something.
So I do get passionate about things that I
wanna do.
So a, I've got a soul.
Second is, I think I'm a very good communicator
when I'm passionate.
Which means that I'm able to get other people
really excited about what I'm excited about.
'Cause it does take a village.
And if you can't get other people excited
about it, it's really hard to be successful
with something.
So, which sort of all adds up in a weird way
to maybe being a good salesman.
Sort of.
Not that I've ever gone out and sort of been
a salesman.
But that's sort of what being a CEO is, right?
You're trying to get everybody going along
with your ideas.
When you're going out to acquire these companies.
All these business you acquire, these people
are making tons of money.
They don't want to sell their businesses.
They had no interest.
But I had to sell them on the fact, that if
they did not sell it to us, there was a wave
that would swamp them at some point.
Four to five years down the road.
'Cause we were gonna go buy everybody else.
And there was going to be a global system.
And if they weren't part of that global system.
But you know, I'm just the outsider just saying
this.
You know, I didn't have anything at the time.
[laughter]
So that is, that's my sort of, biggest skill.
Right?
I'm creative.
I paint, play guitar, stuff like that.
I have an analytical side to me, thankfully.
So I can you know, do spread sheets, but I
don't have a whole lot of patience for it.
You know, accounting, legal, process, other
things.
As we get bigger I get more annoyed with all
the bureaucracy.
And I'm sure it exists here at Google too.
So I don't know if that answers your question.
>>female #1: Hi.
I have two questions actually.
The first is, I, we just learned that, I mean
you guys are based here in Austin.
Great choice on a location by the way.
But I know that you guys are kind of all over
the world.
>>Brian: And we are hiring.
>>female #1: what's that?
>>Brian: We are hiring.
[laughter]
>>female #1: that was gonna be my next question.
I'm just kidding.
But you do have locations around the world.
In fact, my best friend's wife works for your
office in Brazil.
>>Brian: Ah.
Cool.
Wow.
>>female #1: Or one of your partners in Brazil.
So my question is, how did you decide to expand?
What was that critical point where you thought,
OK, we need to be in more countries.
And how did you avoid, hopefully avoid, falling
into the trap of expanding too quickly?
And spreading yourself thin?
I've worked for a company that did that.
So.
He did too.
[laughs]
>>Brian: So the decision to expand internationally
was just a pretty natural fit with the business.
So we're in the travel business.
I mean, just think, for example, if you went
to Expedia and you're about to go to Madrid
and you type in Madrid looking for a hotel
and it says "Sorry, we don't do Madrid."
You're like "That's kinda weird.
You're Expedia.
You should do Madrid."
So it's a worldwide business.
And by definition, we have to cover most of
the major vacation spots around the world.
So expanding to places like Europe makes a
lot of sense.
South America.
Etcetera.
We're still not in Asia.
We have lots of places to go.
And so the first day that we opened our doors,
we acquired both companies in the US and Europe.
Right from day one.
Now, the challenge in terms of how you manage
all that's pretty big.
'Cause you gotta have the right cultural fit
and everything else.
And one of the things we worked really hard
on is communications.
We were, another Austin company here called
Life Size.
A friend of mine here that started was a pioneer
in high definition video conferencing.
And for you know, small startup company, you
don't usually invest in that stuff.
But we invested in it from day one.
We put in an office.
We put in big 60 inch monitors.
We've got a high definition video conferencing.
Because it's just so important for people
to communicate and touch base.
We're also pretty diligent about making sure
that the companies we acquire, English is
the primary, not the primary, but the founders
of those companies speak really good English.
If they don't, they don't make sense to be
there.
If the staff doesn't speak English, we send
in English teachers.
Just because we need to have that communication.
Now in terms of expanding.
You're absolutely right.
We have been, at times, I felt like we've
been on the borderline because one of the
things that's happened to us when you buy
multiple companies in multiple languages,
they come with multiple platforms in multiple
languages.
All those different platforms add complexity
and cost.
We had about 14 different platforms in the
business.
We're now down to four.
We're about to be down to three hopefully
in a couple of months, we have a goal in a
year of being down finally to one platform.
That almost broke us, just from a technology
perspective.
From a people perspective.
From a now that we're public, from a stocks
compliance perspective.
Think about all these platforms and you've
gotta manage all the security holes and risks
and finance stuff and everything else.
And so for that reason, we're not in eastern
Europe.
We're not in Africa.
We're not in Asia.
We're not in China, we're not in Japan.
So we've had to meter it a bit.
And we, this past year, we haven't made any
acquisitions in the last 12 months and the
reason we didn't is 'cause we were taking
the company public and that was just another
big sorta strain on the whole thing.
So we have, it's funny, part of our public
story, we're a little bit unique.
You know you got people out now, whether it's'
Facebook coming out.
People like Pandora.
LinkedIn.
Others.
Who are really in the business right now of
spending as much money as they can to get
as much topline growth as they can.
And we've taken a very different approach
with the market, and have been rewarded with
a pretty good multiple, which is.
We're a little bit different.
We're the disciplined guys.
So we're gonna deliver really steady 30 percent
growth in this business.
And we're gonna make money.
And we're not gonna dump everything.
We can't, sure we could grow the business
faster if we put everything into growth.
If we opened offices all over the world.
And there are a lot of internet companies
that do that.
That's just not our thing.
We just work.
Again it comes back to that little video in
the beginning.
I got my finger burned and so I operate in
a much more risk averse environment.
But there's a group of investors who love
that.
And especially today, that's what they wanna
hear.
So that's the guys we cater to.
There are other people who want growth at
all costs.
And you know they go invest in people like
Pandora, I guess.
Yeah.
>>female #2: Sorry if you, if you answered
this earlier, apologizing in advance.
But, so when you guys were first starting
out, what was your biggest challenge in creating
a following for HomeAway.
When you were brand new?
What kind of tools did you use to gather users
and subscribers?
>>Brian: Most of the early days of this company
was being really good at SEO.
I mean we've got Google to thank.
Clearly for a big chunk of our traffic.
And that was sort of the first couple years.
Then we found religion with paying you guys
lots of money on top of that to goose it.
[audience chatter]
So we paid for that.
Then we got religion around recommendations
and not, and I'll talk about social in a minute,
around really sort of milking our customer
base.
So we got very sophisticated about email marketing,
for example.
So you got millions of people coming in, how
do you make sure that they come back every
year?
I, every time you inquire about a house on
HomeAway we know a lot about you.
We know what you like.
We know when you wanna travel.
And things like that.
So we've a very sophisticated, now, email
program to really keep that flywheel going.
Three years ago I decided that wasn't enough
and it was time for us to start building our
brand.
And so we did, three years ago, start doing
brand marketing.
We're still not big enough to do a huge amount
of it but we started in a big way.
We started with the Super Bowl three years
ago.
We brought back the Griswolds from 'Vacation'
fame.
In fact, we just opened a new office at Penn
Field on South Congress.
Where the Truckster has now its final resting
place in a big garage inside of the office.
And that was sort of a kickoff.
And a year later we did something really stupid.
We did an ad where a baby got thrown against
a window.
And I had to apologize to the world and we
pulled that ad.
[laughter]
But then we got so much publicity from doing
that that it wound up being as good as the
Griswolds.
And then this year, we finally decided to
get out of the Super Bowl game and start getting
into the consistency game.
Right?
And to develop a message that was timeless
and that we could go with for a long time.
That we could run and build over campaign
seasons as opposed to one event like the Super
Bowl.
And it's something I'm really excited about.
I don't know if you've seen it yet.
But it's something.
Our new tag-line for the company is "Let's
stay together."
'Cause we're all about families and friends
getting together in houses.
And the famous Al Green song "Let's stay together"
that Obama was singing just a few months ago,
has now been licensed to us.
So we use that music in the song.
In fact, on April the 26th we are bringing
Al Green to town.
He's gonna play down at ACL.
So any Al Green fans who wanna come to that
show.
It's the first time he's played in two years.
First time he's ever played in Austin.
So that's now how we do it.
As far as social is concerned, we're spending
a lot of time on social as well.
But we haven't really found the magic bullet
on social.
One thing I'll tell you guys that you should
take great comfort in is that we have been
working very hard to replicate the ROI we
get from advertising on Google, by advertising
on Facebook.
And we have a very sophisticated crew of people
that come out of eBay that's testing this
stuff.
Every day and all the time.
As of about a year ago, I reported to my board
that we had gotten the cost of Facebook advertising
down to 300 times the cost of advertising
on Google.
About a year later, with a lot of work, we've
gotten down to Facebook being about 50 times
the cost of advertising on Google.
And so you can feel pretty secure that at
least for a business like HomeAway, we have
not yet found.
People go on social platforms like Facebook
to do other things than look at advertisements.
And for us when you have a product where somebody
is only maybe twice a year, going out.
Right?
You take a couple of vacations a year.
And you may have a two or three day planning
window for each of those vacations.
So six days a year.
I can't hit, we can't, the 50 to one numbers
actually make sense.
Because just randomly, it's hard to sort of
hit those people exactly where in their process.
But with Google of course they go to them
and type in "vacation", "vacation rental",
"looking for a place in Maui."
Whatever it is.
And we can hit them really efficiently.
So social still hasn't been a big thing for
us.
Although we continue to do a lot of work in
that area and maybe someday it will.
Maybe Google+ is the answer for us.
>>male #4: Hi Brian.
First of all lemme just say it's great to
have you here.
Actually my group works directly with you
guys.
>>Brian: Oh, neat.
>>male #4: Through Stephen Goldberg.
>>Brian: Uh-huh.
>>male #4: I'm formerly with DoubleClick.
So my question to you is very simple actually.
How has the mortgage crisis hurt or helped
HomeAway?
>>Brian: I think it's hurt and helped and
they've offset each other.
So if you look at new listings that come into
our business.
And you know they come in at a rate of 30,000,
40,000 listings a quarter that get added to
the pool.
Going back three, four years ago, a huge percentage
of those were new.
So, not actually new units.
But new buyers in the market.
So the vacation market prior to the mortgage
crisis was very hot.
So people were using cheap debt to buy second
homes and you know it's just as it turns out.
And so then developers were building new homes
and about 25 to 30 percent of those people
would just rent them out to help pay those
bills.
So that tap shut off.
In fact the numbers, this is how dramatic
they were.
There were about one point two million vacation
homes being sold a year.
Up until 2008.
That number is now about 400,000 a year.
So it's that bad.
Now the flip side is, that because expenses
have gotten higher for people and part of
the mortgage crisis was remember, people's
interest rates adjusting and all that kinda
stuff.
They were paying nothing and now they actually
have to pay interest.
People who have existing homes have been more
inclined to rent them out.
'Cause they need the money.
And that install base is actually pretty big.
In the US, in Europe, there's about 20 million
people who own vacation homes.
And remember today, in a HomeAway, well, we're
not just in the US and Europe, it's the majority
of our listings.
We have 650,000 homes right now, but there's
20 million of them out there.
And if you go back four or five years ago
when we would survey it, about 25 percent
of the second home owners in the US and Europe
rented.
That number is closer to 30, 31 percent today.
So it's just been trending up year after year.
And the two just have kind of offset each
other.
And the bottom line is we haven't really seen
a huge impact in our trajectory because of
it.
>>male #5: Brian.
Thank you for coming today.
Earlier you mentioned that you went to business
school.
And I've read a lot of literature that argues
that business school may or may not be the
best fit for entrepreneurs.
Maybe they should just jump in.
Could you maybe speak a little bit about that
and your thoughts on how business school did
or did not help you?
>>Brian: Yeah, you know I've thought at times
about writing a book.
And somebody once did.
"What they never taught me at Harvard Business
School" or something like that.
Harvey MacKay or whoever wrote that book.
I feel that way a lot.
That business school was highly academic and
when you get out in the real world, most of
what I've learned I feel like I've learned
sort of pure trial by fire.
And I can't really go back and say "God, if
it weren't for this class, I never would have
been successful."
So that part of it I'd say is true.
The flip side is, I was lucky enough to get
into Stanford Business School.
And Stanford Business School, as is Harvard
Business School.
And maybe there are a few others as well,
comes not just with education but with some
pretty damn good connections.
So if you look at my board for example.
Jeff Brody with Redpoint was one of my buddies
at business school.
Became one of the biggest venture capitalists
in Silicon Valley, him along with Geoff Yang
and John Walecka and his partners, who also
went to Stanford Business School.
The guys are all old friends of mine, he's
on my board.
John Moragne from Trident is one of our early
investors.
He's on our board, from Stanford Business
School, was one of my friends at business
school.
Not that I couldn't have gotten financing
without those guys.
But because of those relationships I gotta
tell ya, it's a lot easier, there's a lot
more trust.
I get to work with friends.
You know?
That I know.
And so there's a net work there at least out
in California that being here in Austin it
would be pretty hard to be tapped into if
I hadn't gone there.
So I donate money to the school and I thank
them every day.
But it's not necessarily because what I learned
in the classroom was the part that I'm applying
in my life at this point.
If that makes sense.
>>male #6: Brian, thank you.
I've talked to a lot of people that have been
employed by HomeAway and they all say that
their hiring process was very unique.
And they felt like they were hired as the
individual rather than filling a specific
position.
And that you take a real pride in people that
you work for, finding, I guess, new opportunities
for them inside your organization.
Can you speak to the benefit of hiring for
individuals rather than filling positions?
>>Brian: yeah.
I mean, I've heard anyway.
Nobody does that better than Google.
So my guess is we're pretty similar in that
regard.
Except that I'm not sure that we give people
brain teasers or math tests or stuff like
that.
[laughter] But it, no, fit is the most important
thing for us.
We really do have a really do have a really
good group of friendly people who like to
work together.
And we stress for everybody that the fit has
to be right like the number one thing I can't
stand is ego.
As I talked about.
We like humble people who don't have big egos.
And so that is as important to us as somebody's
background.
And I think it's for exactly the reason you
say.
When you're a company that's growing fast,
the positions are just gonna kind a change
constantly.
I mean you're constantly having to evolve
and move people to different places.
And so what you hire people fore in the initial
job ends up being pretty irrelevant in a growth
company.
And so you look for the term people use are
"good athletes."
You're looking for good athletes as opposed
to somebody who's really good at a specific
thing.
I don't know if we have any magic formula
and do it any better than anyone else.
I don't think we necessarily people on you
have to ask these kinds of questions.
I think we just hire the kinds of people who
instinctively know that we wanna continue
to hire against our culture.
And it seems to have worked out pretty well.
>>female #3: I have one final question.
What is one of the craziest listings you've
seen on your HomeAway.
>>Brian: I don't know.
Eileen you may know better than me.
Craziest listing.
People have listed some pretty
[audience question off mic]
Oh, that's the best!
[laughter]
That's the best.
So VRBO, actually we bought it.
It was a very religious company actually.
It was like, it was founded by a guy who was
part of this church.
And almost everyone in the company when we
bought it was part of this church.
And it's a pretty conservative deal you know.
They don't drink, they don't.
And so they, people sometimes when they submit
photos will put photos of themselves in bikinis
on the beach.
And they even, bikini, no way.
They would just edit that stuff out.
Well people started, then we bought the company,
people started to do really tricky things.
I'm, people like to see themselves naked online
I guess.
Where they do things like, there'd be a room,
and there'd be a mirror in it.
And you'd see in the mirror them sort of naked
in the background.
[laughter]
So those are the funniest things that happen.
And they, and when it happens, I hate to say
it, it does get passed around.
[laughter]
So.
Makes our day.
[laughter]
[presenter off mic]
>>male #6: You mentioned that you're involved
in maybe investing or part of startups.
Are you actively looking for startups?
And which ones are you already a part of?
And maybe can you expound on that a little
bit?
>>Brian: Yeah, I mean my time is not, I don't
have a lot of free time.
At the moment.
To put a lot into stuff.
So, but I have a sweet spot for people who
like to do entrepreneurial things.
And I love to take their phone calls and I
love to help them.
I speak a lot to entrepreneurs.
And if there are business plans out there
that I get excited about, then I do put money
into things.
And there's a combination of several small
private things that people are working on
and don't necessarily want to disclose yet.
And then I look for in Austin things to get
involved with that I think are pretty hot.
There's a deal here in town.
I mentioned I was on the board of Kayak.
I'm also on the board of a company called
WhaleShark Media here in town you may have
heard of.
And WhaleShark, it's kind of, I would call
it a quasi HomeAway spinout.
'Cause it was started by two guys, Cotter
Cunningham and Justin Halloran.
Justin was one of our senior guys who came
out of eBay and decided to go do WhaleShark
'cause it was a good opportunity for him.
And so I invested with that company.
I'm working with that company.
I think it's a very hot company that's gonna
be a huge success and very excited about it.
And Google Ventures is investing in that company
as well.
They, because of our relationship, they came
in and it's been wonderful.
So yeah, if you've got something cool, I'd
love to hear about it.
>>Female Presenter: Well, I want to everybody
for showing up today, and we wanna give you
a Google Awesome t-shirt on behalf of Google
Talks.
[applause]
>>Brian: Yay!
I was actually jealous.
There's so many people wearing Google stuff.
People are never wearing HomeAway stuff.
We don't give out enough, I guess.
[laughter]
>>Brian: Anyway, thank you, that's wonderful.
I appreciate it.
Oh!
I spoke.
Y'all.
Pretty hip.
Cool.
Thanks.